hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast unlocking the potential
of the laboratory through clinical
decision support presented by Todd
Wharton and Katherine Metz of ABBA
Diagnostics I'm Christie jewel of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
educational web seminars brought to you
by lab routes and sponsored by Abbott
Diagnostics for more information on our
sponsor please click on the Abbott logo
at the left side of your screen now
let's get started I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
wanted anytime you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
the send button we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation additionally we will
be conducting a few polls throughout the
presentation and we appreciate your
participation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen the presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I would now like to
introduce you to our speakers Todd
Wharton and Katherine Metz both Abbott
clinical solution consultants additional
information can be found on their
backgrounds in the biography tab at the
top of your screen Katherine
you may now begin today's presentation
thank you very much Christy welcome
everyone thanks for joining I'm going to
begin by talking about this title flip
page that you should be able to see
clearly in front of you and highlighting
that while it's may be an attractive
picture of health care occurring it's
absolutely vital to us an Abbott to make
sure that we let all of our customers
know and the health care system at large
now that we really value lab data and
laboratorians and their role in the
healthcare system so this breaking
through walls and bringing down barriers
between the lab and the rest of the
healthcare system we think is absolutely
critical and that's really behind the
theme of what we're here to talk about
today with clinical decision support
our objectives today as you probably saw
in the invitation is to review the
strategic imperatives that drive the
need for clinical decision support
encourage a common language related to
the clinical decision support process
and especially to encourage a broader
participation in this process so not
just for the laboratory team and lab
leadership but beyond the lab and
including everyone within the healthcare
system not just those that are in
planning or Quality Assurance for
example will be providing specific
examples and applications of effective
clinical decision support implementation
and talk about ways to select
high-impact projects I can effectively
target clinical variability clinical
variability issues and other key
initiatives
by way of background I want to highlight
some things that I think we're all
pretty familiar with but to really hone
in on some of the real priority ones
here that are common to us all some are
positive some are negative some you
might say are neutral or to be
determined the reimbursement cuts that
we're all seeing staffing shortages
certainly create great challenges for us
patient volumes are going up in terms of
new payer models or hospital
consolidation you might say those are
neutral maybe positive maybe negative
depending on your market but absolutely
the access to greater information is
perceived as overall positive but a
great opportunity and something that
we're all striving to make the most of
and to harness the power of that
additional information
further as the volume of diagnostic
information has fuels of complexity and
of clinical decision making and
prescribers as well as other clinical
team members really have lots of
day-to-day demands on their time and so
more locally it's time pressure the vast
volume of information such as chemistry
and hematology data that according to
one survey each primary care physician
each week has nine hundred and thirty
pieces to process and physicians who've
got questions about what it is they want
to test how they want to interpret it
they've got questions that they're
either not asking or they're not getting
answers to
in addition the presence of diagnostic
errors has been an issue and it
continues to be a serious issue medical
errors are considered to be the third
leading cause of death in the United
States at least one in 20 adults
experience a diagnostic error annually
in the course of seeking health care and
diagnostic errors account for coming up
to a third of malpractice claims and
more than a third of total payments for
malpractice at this point we're going to
take a break for a moment and ask you to
complete a brief survey and we'll share
the results with everyone so there's a
survey that should be appearing in front
of you and we're asking you to think
about where you think diagnostic errors
occur as they relate to laboratory
testing so we've got answers a through e
so we're even if it's in multiple places
where do you think the primary place
where diagnostic errors occur as they
relate to lab testing
during the clinical question test
selection and ordering during sample
collection transport and specimen prep
while the testing themselves or test
themselves are being performed
then afterwards upon validation report
generations sharing results ordering the
interpretation reading interpretation
and taking actions that phase
so then give you a few more moments to
respond it looks like we have
like 50 or so folks that have responded
and we're going to give you another
moment here
Christie should go ahead and close do
you think we have the response to slow
down
okay and we're going to send the results
so that you can see them
and are you all able to slide confirm
Christie I can go ahead wonderful so as
you can see from the results for all of
you that are participating on our call
today there are certainly a variety of
places where diagnostic errors occur and
I think you're going to be I'm happy to
see that you're you're fairly close to
what the literature says our audience is
looking at more than a third of the time
it's during that initial ordering test
collection process heavily in the sample
collection transport and prep and then
during their reading interpretation and
decision-making process I'm going to
proceed with the rest of the
presentation here and you'll see that
that's consistent and although there are
results are even more dramatic in that
regard so most diagnostic errors truly
do occur outside the laboratory I think
all of our lab team members and
customers that are on the phone that our
day-to-day responsible for high quality
fast test performance that's that job is
getting done it's getting job done day
to day but it's really those things that
are very often outside your control on
one end or the other it's that is where
more attention needs to be paid to the
quality of test results this also
reinforces the importance of lab being
involved beyond the lab in terms of
supporting how that initial selection
test ordering process occurs at the end
on how things are interpreted and how
decisions are made as well as the other
stages in the testing process
I'm going to take a look now at what the
c-suite executives CEOs CFOs and such
what their priorities are and some
literature and some data on what their
opinions are related to lab and the take
home here is that as you can see on the
left one key point is that lab is right
up there with other key players in terms
of the labs importance in delivering key
performance indicators so they're
important drivers you know almost as
much as you could say lab but right
there with Lao finance with pharmacy a
key component of delivering KPIs and
that the c-suite does have a specific
that does value the lab in providing
specific solutions and the c-suite has
specific expectations of the lab to
impact patient satisfaction be a part of
healthcare analytics and leverage that
data and participate in the test
ordering process so as I talked about in
the very beginning with moving beyond
the lab and changing the focus and
switching from a more internal
operational efficiency lab production
type of focus to more external and being
more involved in strategic imperatives
having a seat at the table to drive
initiatives with that throughout the
institution and we're going to be
talking about some of the ways that the
lab can participate and even lead in
this process
so in this illustration we're going to
be talking about this brick wall in the
center that might be perceived and that
is between not always but but critically
between physicians ordering tests and
the physicians that are responsible for
putting those results out there for
interpretation and to take action so for
example on the left left we've got very
busy physicians that are involved in
with many many patients at different
phases of the care process diagnosis
diagnosis to treatment and they have a
very limited amount of time and on the
right we're representing diagnostic
doctors such as radiologists
pathologists and those that are putting
out that information and sometimes it
can be perceived that there's there's a
wall there it's just receiving orders to
perform certain tests and you could say
throwing the data over the wall and
we're proposing here that there is often
a disconnect are the results and reports
actually being seen by the prescribers
and those ordering the tests are they
interpreting the results properly and
other results integrated with other
information that the physicians are
using in a meaningful way and we would
propose that there's definitely room for
improvement there
and on the positive side however we can
say that healthcare care providers or
primarily physicians really are allies
to our lab partners and to laboratorians
and lab leaders they do want better
communication and collaboration and they
want more detailed information they want
guidance as they receive these results
they want more consultation and
additional interpretive information to
help support the diagnostic process and
further they have not a lot of training
in lab tests and a very small amount of
medical school education is devoted to
diagnostic testing and understanding the
tests that they'll be receiving results
on so they want more training and in
addition on new standards new tests that
are available so they're really looking
for more support so physicians are the
labs ally and that's why we feel it's
very important that chief medical
officers and service line leaders be
involved hand-in-hand with lab directors
in looking at how best to leverage lab
and other data to reduce clinical
variability and reduce diagnostic errors
and really participate in these quality
and operational strategic projects that
are in place
so overall we've been talking about a
shift between the lab functioning as
more of a cost center to a more integral
part of creating value in the healthcare
system so I'd say the one word here I'd
like to highlight is up at the top so
transforming so the we want to see our
lab partners have be less isolated and
more integrated and more participatory
in the clinical decision support process
and I'll also highlight that you know we
we do here when we're speaking to our
customers and health systems all across
the country that EMRs are looked upon as
kind of a be-all end-all solution but
we're seeing that they're really not
fully fully leveraging the lab at most
institutions and the approach with the
EMR is really trying to tackle
everything at once and that results in
not being able to be very nimble it
takes a long time and it's lots of very
large projects that can always be
modified as new clinical information and
new guidance comes to the fore that we
want to respond to so what we're going
to propose here is for us to think about
what if you could leverage your current
lab data as well as other lab data such
as within the system to perform some of
these things so we're not going to go
through all of these in detail but the
purpose here is for you to think about
what kinds of projects that you're
involved with the tasks that you're
called upon beyond test you know lab
tests production that would have value
within your institution because we
really feel that labs do have power to
improve test ordering interpretation
such as providing guidance and education
and reminders in a patient's specific
way to physicians and other team members
decreasing clinical variability is is
critical to improve compliance with
protocols that you already have in place
and that currently exists but are just
not
enough traction patient flow and
throughput increase means faster
precision of data for decision-making
and by gapsin care we're referring to
for example lack of follow-up on testing
that's occurred or needing better
follow-up on patients who are post
discharge to help decrease readmission
rates risk stratification and impacting
value-based care is leveraging data to
target key populations such as with
outreach and then finally all of you are
with institutions that have current
safety and quality initiatives in place
and lab is involved in those whether it
be to just to support those initiatives
that are already happening by looking at
lab data as well as other data sources
and we want to make sure that we foster
that participation
I'm going to pass it over to Todd to
continue with the presentation and I'm
checking to make sure do we have any of
could we have a question about slide 6
so sorry about that I missed that I'm
going to go back to slide 6 for a moment
and look at the questions so sorry about
that folks
and I apologize I've gotta look in the
right spot under new questions and
Christy I'm actually not seeing it under
new questions so okay thank you
so the question here is regarding
frequency I understand the higher
numbers in the pre and post examination
can you comment about severity or
Consequences with diagnostic error well
I'll come to do that and just really
giving some examples so for you know not
just the frequency but really what the
impact is here so clinical question test
selection and ordering I think the one
that really comes to mind and that's the
most prominent is are the right tests
being ordered you know we focus and many
of our customers focus on too much
testing especially high cost tests so
it's not just that it's sometimes not
using assays that are considered
appropriate for current standards of
practice let's say for example using
panels where we could just be using
individual tests to save money so test
selection is really critical critical
not just over test utilization could be
under utilization and appropriate tests
and on the other side in terms of how
results are read interpreted and
decisions taken I think we can all agree
that physicians have such a vast
quantity of information to sort through
and if we can help them to focus on it
and provide recommendations on now what
is there additional reflux testing that
we recommend occurs or in the actual
results themselves can we provide
information on the reference or the
source that this refers to and help them
understand the cascade of testing that
might need to occur so we want to make
sure that physicians have information
fast and the right information to
support their decisions and at this part
after the tests have already been
released and you know it's up to the
back to take their to take their steps
we can definitely provide them with
additional support that
to practice
and Todd I'm going to hand it over to
you I think I was on flight 11 and take
it away thank you
captain very much so I'm going to give
you a little bit of an overview of the
decision support tool and the
opportunities that we have to impact
your population at multiple points in
care we can help with patient flow
that's Kathleen mentioned streamlining
provider order entry so if we really
want to look at something like genetic
tests or you you look at the redundancy
and multiple alerts and clinical
guidelines but if we talk about genetic
testing it's a very costly task that
that multiple organizations need to
perform but how can we effectively look
at the point of entry to really
determine the appropriateness based on
the diagnosis and previous tests that
have been performed to really impact
that patient flow and provide effective
cost of both effective care in the
patient flow and cost effective care as
well we can also help with risk
stratification if you're looking at
customer scores that you may be
developing as an organization for opioid
screening or any number of issues that
you may want to address we can also help
as Kathryn mention with with care gap
closure and looking at that within your
specific disease states like congestive
heart failure or diabetes where we need
specific exams and items that need to
occur throughout the continuum of care
we can also help with again high risk
stratification and look at intervention
and targeting specific patients for
outreach and addressing factors within
social determinants of health because
our solution is is both data and vendor
agnostic so we don't really care where
the data is coming from we can
processing it into the solution as words
we will discuss here in the future and
and look at how we can help that to be
addressed within your organization again
really helping the lab break down the
barriers not just clinically but we can
help you to address
things along the financial continuum of
care so that you can address your
patient population before your claims
are being dropped and really impact that
care along your patient population so
how does it work right we're taking that
data in from disparate data sources and
inputting it into the decision engine
we're running it against organizational
configured rules and I think that really
is a key component a lot of folks out
there are using different EHRs and those
EHRs are great at what they're able to
do but they're not going to be focused
on how your particular organization is
practicing medicine or how your
particular organization is functioning
as a lab so we allow you to configure
that so that every time a particular
patient requires a more complex
diagnosis or decision we can apply the
rule to that particular logic and
analyze it against the relevant
historical patient information against
those multiple data sources and provide
patient and organizational specific
diagnostic information to help
clinicians to get more accurate patient
information and get high quality
interpreting of results again with
patient specific treatment
recommendations so if their specific
Cascades like anaemia coagulopathy where
they need more help from those
diagnostic doctors that Kathryn referred
to and breaking down those walls we can
really help to bridge that gap real time
and provide better information without
forcing a physician to go into another
system to gain information or to call
another doctor for an interpretation we
can give all that to them real time in a
interpretation that you'll see here
shortly
the flow work right all of you out there
are dealing with more and more complex
data sources you're adding new
instruments into your lab maybe you're
transitioning to a new lis we talked
about how
our system is both vendor and data
agnostic so if you're going through a
transition into a new lis we can
transition from a Sun quest to a beaker
or meditech or CERN or any of those
particular systems accommodate that LIF
information look at the historical data
in both the LIF and the EHR move into
the second area where we would request
an interpretation look at the patient
specific results and then put that
feedback information into a loop that's
going to build knowledge within the
system generate an interpretation we can
flag reports that need additional
validation we can also add reflux
testing with patient specific results
and historical result data in there for
that reflux and we can also update the
rule information real-time this can all
be done without meaning to reach out to
your EHR vendor without needing to reach
out to us and management configured by
your organization internally
so some examples of rules and comments
that can be created as I mentioned we
can flag prior treatments or diagnosis
like the patient has a history of
chronic kidney disease how are we
addressing that what types of things may
be occurring throughout the continuum of
care that may be putting this patient in
for
additional information and looking at
their renal compromised we can remind
that clinician of previous test results
in real-time so they've had a previous
impaired GTT do we need to look at their
a1c or additional information again
provide additional context and we'll
look at some specific pathways on how we
can do that we can provide additional
recommendations on clinical guidelines
looking at previous Bluecoats levels and
as I mentioned maybe we need to suggest
an a1c or perhaps the patient is hot
anyone see six months ago but the
clinician wasn't able to find that
information easily we can go ahead and
do that very easily and we can also
remind the physician of specific test
intervals as well
you
so additional workflow actions and
things that we can implement we can
provide email or SMS alerts to members
of your clinical staff members of your
laboratory staff members of your revenue
cycle top excuse me
staff to address patient specific
information and as we discussed we can
automate reflux testing based on
particular triggers and provide that
workflow directly into the lis
so we can go ahead and
our items in
the application as far as opioid
enhancement as well and how we're going
to build out your enhanced opioid
management so some of the data points
that we're able to configure and add
into the system are a prescription
history the opioid metabolites key terms
from particular tests Fields has this
particular patient ever been
administered narcan what is their
prescriptive history look like what is
their pregnancy status is there any
mention of particular abuse this is
relevant in multiple points within the
lab continuum if you're trying to build
out your outreach and you want to engage
some of the pain management clinics that
may be surrounding your organization to
go out and target them for better
management of their patient population
and all of the opioid screening that
they're having to do we can impact that
along multiple touchpoints in the
continuum of care as you're looking at
here so if we want to look at the
patient upon admission into the IDI if
they're in a pre-op setting or
postoperatively how does this patient do
with multiple different opioids have
they refused an opioid prescription in
the past all of that particular data can
then go in and affect outcomes to really
increase your opioid abuse risk
identification look at prescription
compliance monitoring frequency in the
need for perhaps more screening at those
pain management clinics or we want to
just increase overall prescriber
awareness of pain management
alternatives and really if we can do
anything as clinicians to to help with
the opioid crisis we're going to be
showing something positive to our
organization so really changing the way
the lab is going to impact these
patients across the continuum of care
but really what we're talking about here
as we said is we want to break down the
barriers and change how folks look at
the lab you know I'm a former ER nurse
and I was always the guy at the other
end of the phone who was calling the lab
to demand my results faster tell them
there was clearly no way that I could
have hemolyzed the sample but what we're
talking about is really transforming the
lab from numbers into action so if we
want to look at something side by side
in a disease state like sepsis and how
we address that as an organization
everybody's clearly focused on lactate
values blood culture turnarounds because
these are things that our organizations
are being measured by CMS on and they
haven't changed so we can certainly get
that number like in this slide we can
see in our particular example here we
have a lactate of 2.1 we're running a
PCT and that particular value is 36 so
we can then respond with a solution in
real time giving the clinician
information like the fact that our PCT
is extremely high the fight excuse me
despite the fact that the lactate is
near normal we can also track your
lactate times for those particular
turnaround times like you may be
interested in for your core measure
compliance but if we want to be more
insightful we can provide information
like the PCT value is high and it's
obviously suggesting a bacterial
infection that may not be adequately
controlled now we don't really know
where this particular patient is in
their journey through your healthcare
organization but perhaps you want to
have a more in-depth conversation with
folks from your antibiotic stewardship
team and say look are we really looking
at the use of PCT and effective
antimicrobial stewardship something that
is really important to organizations and
you know the mark on this type of thing
changes frequently so it's hard to get
these types of initiatives going within
EHRs where it may
take a backseat to larger organizational
initiatives so if you can drive this
type of change and as captain was
showing you really change your KPIs and
your organizational quality metrics and
recommend actions like switching
antibiotics to your excuse me switching
your antibiotic treatment continuing to
monitor your PCT wbcs and other clinical
values like you know is this patient
febrile do we want to consider
discontinuing an antibiotic treatment as
soon as possible
so being able to pull in data from
multiple sources across this patient's
journey through all of these different
data areas really is helpful to
transform the lab from just somebody
that spits out those results in a
manufacturing engine to something that
is more supportive and contributes to
the decision making process
so then how do we evolve right we're
looking at an example algorithm again of
sepsis and PCT and I realized that you
know there we can have a whole separate
discussion about PCT and I'm not here to
talk to you about PCT use and you can
plug in lactate here in a similar
algorithm and really anything you wanted
to do if you wanted to talk about
coagulopathy or anemia we can use very
similar algorithms here and build them
out very simply so if I want to look at
my PCT value
consider either initiating or
discontinuing antibiotics and look at
those recommendations and provide the
recommendations that you're seeing down
here in blue so do we want to look at
different diagnoses do we want to repeat
a PCT look at the risk profile of this
particular patient and then we want to
continue to follow them and perhaps have
an opportunity to discontinue our
antibiotic earlier
then if we want to look at another
crucial disease state like heart failure
and how we can really go ahead and
augmenting path ways for that we can do
that with clinical values in decision
support for heart failure
and look at things like our patient's
weight our respiratory status but if we
really want to go in and take it to a
whole nother level we can look at Galton
3 and see how the particular patient if
they're looking like they're going to be
somebody that is going to be at high
risk for progressing down heart failure
and decreasing their renal function we
can look at those particular values and
perhaps have an opportunity to counsel
them earlier if they're low risk or if
they're moderate risk do we want to get
them into a long-term care management
program if they're high-risk do we want
to go more intensively and perhaps
readmit them or have a different
discussion with with their caregivers
and how we're going to impact these
particular individuals along the
continuum of care so at this point here
you guys are going to get a break from
having to listen to me and I'm sure
you're thankful for that and we're going
to go in and have another survey
so okay
our survey here
we'll go ahead and give you guys an
opportunity to respond to that survey
and then in just a minute I'll go ahead
and return to the last couple slides and
then we'll give you an opportunity to
ask some questions
you
again just to reiterate what protocols
are
clinical guidelines is your organization
trying to implement and what role is a
laboratory playing in this process you
know and I think we could we probably
get a pretty diverse group of answers
here I'll be really interested to hear
everybody's responses because you know
some organizations out there they're
really doing a terrific job of engaging
the lab and and they want to have much
different conversations then folks that
may be there they're those folks that
are really trying to break through that
wall that we talked about and they're
really struggling I feel like sometimes
I'm frequently struggling against that
wall and and really I welcome those days
when I feel like I can just smash
through it and have good engaging
conversations with folks like y'all
I think we've given everybody an
adequate time to respond to our survey
here and I'm going to move on so we're
just going to briefly talk about right
characteristics of a successful product
excuse me of a successful project and I
really see this as an opportunity for us
to talk about a successful product at
all of these different data sources that
we have right so if we look at all the
different data that's available to me
that really represents all of the
different colors that we have here
feeding our patient picture right we're
pulling that all in and you may have a
disparate LIF from your EHR maybe your
organization is even using a different
practice management system so how can
not only the lab but other individuals
get a good picture of what's going on
in the patient population here we have
some strategic imperatives quality
initiatives and variability we want to
go ahead and look at organizational and
financial risk to really then determine
is this going to be relevant
so I'm in a pause here I see that we
have a question here as we finish
talking up about the characteristics of
the successful product excuse me I want
to say product all day today apparently
and instead of project and I'm an
apposite there was a question in regards
to opioid management can it in interface
with States PMP and the answer to that
is is yes we can interface with
prescription drug monitoring programs
and help you to go out and query those
particular systems so it just really is
going to depend on how your particular
organization wants to handle that and
where that's going to fall in the
treatment pathways with your patient
population but I think again a great
conversation and as I stressed here with
our data slide really we don't care
where that data comes from right we can
ingest it into the system and then build
a particular rule for how we're going to
handle your patient treatment
you
and then let's see
very valid point here in
another question regarding the project
slide the feedback loop and area for
improvement seems to be missing from the
characteristics of a successful project
and I think that you know I would agree
with that but I but what we're trying to
really get away from is really looking
at as just a single evaluation at the
continual evaluation in the circle there
and so that's really what we're we're
getting at with the evaluation of the
successful project is it's an ongoing
evaluation but certainly we could add
another element into our feedback loop
there to evaluate that successful
project thank you for the feedback so
again how do we suggest excuse me select
priority initiatives as an organization
we want to look at particular internally
identified projects and what are your
quality teams doing there do we need to
look at external organizations and we
want to make sure and choose wisely
there so you know do we need to focus on
Joint Commission and patient safety
goals obviously very very important and
we can help you do that within the lab
like we talked about looking at
particular metrics for you know lactates
or turnaround times and how can you work
with business partners like us to go
ahead and move through best practices
and proactively share innovations so I'm
going to pause here and see what other
questions we have and then you know
we'll continue so folks out there that
have been very patient and waiting til
the end for your questions and sort of
really thinking up good ones we'd love
to hear it so go ahead and and just jump
in there and ask away on questions if
you if you need assistance on where you
can provide those we'll certainly give
that to you so I'm going to pause
Thank You Todd and Catherine - for your
informative presentation yes we will
start asking some more questions and as
a reminder if you do have any questions
to ask please do so now use that ask a
question box that's located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for okay so let's get started
Todd and Catherine I'll ask it generally
to both of you and then whoever would
like to answer just go ahead and chime
in okay so let's start with this
question oh my god several questions
coming in let's see okay my physicians
already don't read the information the
lis provide how will this make them pay
attention to critical or new information
can I'd be happy to take that one
so thank you for the question this is
Catherine again so physicians we do hear
this often when we're talking to
partners physicians have a lot of
information to look at is it going to be
perceived as yet something else too to
look at the information that is
available invisible to physicians and
other clinicians is not a separate
screen it's not something new that they
have to go out and look at and pull from
so we're talking about including
information that appears in the same
place where their current lab results
are pushed but it's supplemented with
information that's crafted by our
individual hospitals and systems and
using physician leadership and
involvement in that process so if
there's for example cardiology certain
clinical variability that's occurring
now and non-compliance with certain
pathways or difficulty interpreting
information that's coming over to them
the recommendation would be to work with
physicians in that area to get consensus
on it and also to help develop what that
messaging looks like or at least have
them looked at that and vet it in
advance so that they know what it is
that their physicians are going to be
seeing in those situations where the
where the the clinical variables apply
so it's not something new that they need
to go out and seek a look at it's a part
of the same information that they're
viewing so this is generally perceived
very positively and it's not oh this is
just another pop up that I have to kind
of work through so we want this
information to be meaningful and to be a
part of their decision process and their
evaluation
Catherine let's go with this next
question how do you assure that you
avoid introducing alert fatigue when
designing decision support tools
so I'll take a pass at this
Catherine and then you can feel free to
add info here I think it's very
important to address alert fatigue we
all know that that's a huge problem with
physicians and what we're trying to do
and again configuring this solution is
design it so that it's going to meet
your organizational specific needs so if
we want to add additional information if
Catherine mentioned if we want to email
or text other members of the team so
that we can impact things at the point
of care without impacting the physician
workflow we certainly have the
opportunity the key takeaway here is
that we're able to configure the
solution based on the organizational
needs some organizations have had
success with pop-ups but others are like
most across the country where they
really feel like they're being bombarded
and so we want to deliver a solution
that is going to be something that's
going to be beneficial to the
organization and not impact that
workflow in an unsatisfactory manner
Thank You Todd and let's see a few more
questions coming in can system help
physicians interpret potential
contaminated blood cultures now this is
a few part consistent health visit
consistent health physicians interpret
potential contaminated blood cultures
and consistent provide guidelines for
using antibiotics and what antibiotics
to use have systems that have
implemented the system used algorithm
results as recommendations or
requirements and final comment in this
question force the issue of patient is
seen at various HD facilities in order
for system to access data and makes
decision
I'll take this one thank you and I can
see it Thank You Christy in the to be
answered question so so I'm going to
take this piece by piece and not
necessarily in order the answer to most
is yes but we'll break that up so in
terms of helping physicians interpret
potential contaminated blood cultures
the short answer is it's easy whenever
something's available in the lis to be
able to have that as a trigger so as
long as that's information that's in
there that we want to highlight and
provide additional interpretive
information to the doc we can absolutely
do that can assistant provide guidance
for using antibiotics and what
antibiotics to use yes and I think
earlier when Todd was showing the one
portion of a sepsis protocol algorithm
there are some examples there in terms
of basically the decision tree and at
what point in the decision tree do we
want to push certain information that
would help to provide that information
we can do so and further to kind of
reinforce what Todd was just saying
about the quantity of info that Doc's
get and who gets information provided to
them an example there might be that
maybe it's the recommendation goes to
someone on the pharmacy team as well or
it's in two places its viewed in the
information that comes through with the
let with the lab results and it's also
alerting a particular distribution list
or team or texting members of pharmacy
teams so they can see that information
faster and make changes more promptly
the question about have systems that
have implemented this used algorithm
results as recommendations or
requirements yes that's that's part and
parcel to what we're talking about here
so we're not approaching our customers
and saying here's new practice that you
should be instituting it's what are
those practices that you already have in
place or algorithms you want physicians
to be considering and complying with and
that's where we start
that's where the recommendations and the
rules that are built in the system begin
and be you know and that's where the how
those are built around so hopefully I'm
answering that question and I really
like this last piece of the question the
writer has C go back to the answered
ones it says I foresee an issue with I'm
going to paraphrase because I'm not
seeing it in front of me about here it
is if patient is seen at various
healthcare facilities in order for the
system to access the data and make
decisions so one of the things that we
we did not highlight here is that really
anywhere within the healthcare system
that we can bring data into we can use
that to make decisions so I have one
customer that is talking about how
patients receive testing at one hospital
and then they might be transferred to
the academic medical center and concern
about information being lost in
translation there but if we can make
sure that we're including in the the
setup that all that information is
available we're looking at what setting
that was they were in setting a and this
is what the results are they're now in
setting B whether that's transition to a
different part of the hospital or a
different setting of care all together
outpatient inpatient or one hospital to
another one of those data variables is
what's setting therein so we're able to
look at that so if we want to target
patients in particular who are moving
from outpatient inpatient or looking at
one hospital to another depending on
what that algorithm is that's anything
that's a data element we can use that as
a factor and it's not something that
would be excluded so at the end of the
day what we're talking about here is
that we're not
it's saying well we can only look at
those patients that are inpatients we
can't look at anything outside of that
so it is within scope and it's part of
the the process that we go through and
talking to our customers about what
problems they're looking to solve
clinically and operationally and we can
include those data elements
Thank You Katherine now our next
question can the physician see the
information about the cost of certain
lab tests and where where a reference
lab test may be set to
so I'll speak to that I think you know
that's certainly an option for an
organization to provide a physician with
cost information but I do think that
that opens up a pretty big can of worms
that may be difficult to to deal with
but the alternative would be to make a
recommendation to a physician that they
haven't perhaps chosen the most
effective reference lab for a send out
test or that the fact that they've
chosen to send out tests and in all
likelihood the particular send out maybe
be able to be performed by Amber's
Methodist Health System for instance
so there is opportunity for us to
address that and amber if you don't feel
that I've answered that question
appropriately then feel free to ask for
some more insight there but we can
really help you to address not only your
send out prior to send out but we can
also look at your reference lab
information and build a more complex
interpretation and more detailed usable
information for those diagnostic doctors
on your team
Thank You Todd now looks like we have
time for just a few more questions uh
maybe we can we can slip one more in
here let's end with this doesn't this
increase the number of steps physicians
have to take an order in um to take to
order or interpret our physicians are
already unhappy with pop-ups and number
of applications how is this any
different
Christie I'm just looking I apologize I
was looking at the answered questions
and so I need to get a better view of
this I can make sure that I answer that
properly so physicians are there more
steps and I guess we could also say we
want to make sure them that we try to
make physicians no more unhappy than
they already are
so in terms of ordering or interpreting
I guess you could say with ordering it
might be an additional step but it's
that's only in those situations where it
looks like there's inappropriate
ordering either over or under ordering
that's taken place and I think we've
established and and most of us can agree
that that guidance is something
physicians are asking for when it
happens at the moment of ordering
sometimes that's not always good news
but what we've seen is that the vast
majority of physicians want additional
help and guidance in what tests to write
and partnering with physicians as an
organization targets what areas to to
really go for first to create efficiency
as well as reduce clinical variability
it's making those choices you know
picking which physician audiences which
clinical areas to begin with you know
might not be sepsis maybe it's related
to coagulopathy as we talked about or
maybe transitioning from one level of
care to another so there's lots and lots
of options and that's one of the reasons
why we wanted to highlight that
characteristics of a successful project
there's so many ways to use clinical
decision support and really prioritizing
which ones make sense for your
organization and I know for for Todd Nye
that's something that we most enjoy is
talking about not just the tool but how
it can help our individual customers
with what they're challenged with and
trying to help them talk through
prioritizing so that these are valuable
and you know there's always disruption
with change but we want to do them in
such a way that the physicians feel good
about them too because it can be
demonstrated look we've cut down on
waste or we've sped up the process in
these particular areas so it's a part of
what what projects are selected so and
in terms of are there additional steps
in interpreting similar there might be
similarly there's additional information
that's provided to help them interpret
and the ultimate goal is for them to
feel better about the information that's
provided to them
they may realize oh I don't have to do
this additional test or yes maybe I do
have to do another test it's a part of
the process in providing and
supplemental clinical information so
it's not a forced you must do these you
know these following things but here's
the protocol as it exists that your
department is has endorsed and you know
here's more information to help guide
you through the next steps so hopefully
that's that's addressed this in terms of
you know physician steps I think we have
talked before about pop-ups and you know
you know as we've said that you know if
there are data elements and algorithms
that the Eleniak youcbs
implementation targets that you want to
feed into a pop up in your EMR that can
we can do that but we don't want we want
to make it perfectly clear that this is
not a our CVS solution is not a pop-up
machine and we want to make sure that
we're judicious about not only what
projects and and challenges we help our
customers to address but also what's the
best way to attack those additional
those individual clinical variability
revenue or interpretive issues that they
may have
how does there anything you would add on
this one
no I think you did a wonderful job
summarizing it so I'll just be the first
to say thank you everybody for tuning in
we appreciate your participation and
hope that you found today's session
valuable
Thank You Todd and Catherine now do
either of you have any final comments
for our audience before we go
no thank you
thank you both again for your time today
and for your important research and we'd
also like to thank elaborate and our
sponsor Abba Diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
I do want to also thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
now questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during our
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speakers via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on-demand and
laborat swill alert via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
at the close of this event a survey will
pop up on your screen your participation
is appreciated and your answers help
improve our webinar program until next
time goodbye